ستستمر هذه على الأرجح ثلاثة أسابيع.
تتلقى القوات الأوكرانية درسًا في
صناعة السندات السرية
[موسيقى]
المتفجرات البريطانية
والمتخصصون في مكافحة التمرد ينقلون
عقودًا من الخبرة إلى جنود على دراية
جيدة بالفعل بالقتال العادي على الخطوط الأمامية
ويحاولون أن
يتذكروا، لكن هذه ليست عادية  القنابل
هي أسلحة سرية في
ترسانة أوكرانيا السرية لقتل الروس على
الأراضي الأوكرانية إذا كان لدينا
هدف ذو أولوية عالية، فنحن بالطبع نستخدم هذه
المعدات ضدها وهي
ليست مجرد أهداف فردية، فقد تم
استخدام تكنولوجيا مماثلة بالفعل في أيدي أوكرانية ذات خبرة كبيرة
لإسقاط  بناءً على العشرات من
القوات الروسية التي تم نشرها مؤخرًا في باك الطين،
تُستخدم هذه المعدات لتدمير العدو، نستخدمها
لإنتاج أجهزة متفجرة
يمكننا استخدامها على الأرض في
ساحة المعركة أو في الجو كذخيرة
للطائرات بدون طيار،
ولكنها ليست مجرد مهارات تخريبية
و  التقنيات التي يجلبها الخبراء البريطانيون
مطلوبة في العمليات السرية،
فهي مكونات القنبلة
ومفاتيح متطورة للغاية
ورقائق دقيقة متخصصة ونظارات للرؤية الليلية
وأجهزة مراقبة سرية، وحتى الطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد التي
يسهل شراؤها نسبيًا خارج أوكرانيا،
وهي مطلوبة بشدة لأن القوات هنا
في سباق مع الزمن ضد  إن
وصول الروس إلى
شركاء الناتو يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً، ومن الصعب
قياس هذه المساعدة بالكلمات أو
الأرقام لأنها تمثل دعمًا معنويًا كبيرًا
لنا مباشرة إلى قلوبنا
ونحن ممتنون جدًا لهذه
المساعدة، فهي إجراء حتى عشية  من
المتوقع حدوث هجوم مضاد كبير بشأن
مقدار المساعدة التي لا يزال الجيش الأوكراني
بحاجة إليها، والتي بعد مرور أكثر من عام على
الحرب، حتى أصغر المكونات،
وأكثر المساعدات العملية تواضعًا، يتم
تلقيها بامتنان شديد، نيك روبنسون، سي إن إن
شرق أوكرانيا
الخارجية